before Einstein our understanding of  time was basically due to Newton and it  aligned with our intuition time in the  mathematics of Newton is pretty much  time as we experience it when Einstein  came along that all changed with the  special theory of relativity he showed  that past present and future that kind  of way of dividing up our understanding  of time that isn't as fundamental as you  would think it is he showed in essence  that different observers in the world  moving with respect to one another  different speeds won't agree on what is  past present and future  what's past for me might be future for  someone else what's present for me might  be past for someone else so when you  take it all together past present and  future are not a kind of demarcation  that's universal in fact Einstein  summarized this to the widow of a close  friend of his by trying to console her  by saying that past present and future  that's only an illusion however  persistence  you